- [Narrator] In this video,
we're gonna talk about food webs,
which is really just a way
of picturing how all of the matter,
and how all of the energy
flows inside of an ecosystem.
Now, when I talk about matter,
I'm talking about the
atoms in an ecosystem,
the molecules, when you look at your hand,
it is made up of atoms.
And it turns out that the matter
is not created or destroyed,
it's just recycled
throughout an ecosystem.
And we're going to see that in a second.
And then when we talk about energy,
it's the energy that your
cells need to be alive,
the energy you need to be
alive, to not just exist,
but to do things, to think, to move.
And so this food web
essentially describes that.
As we've talked about in other videos,
in most ecosystems, the
great majority of the energy
in an ecosystem comes from the sun.
So what we have here is
the sun produces energy.
It travels to Earth,
and then you have organisms,
which we would call producers,
that are able to take that
light energy from the sun,
and then take atoms and
molecules from its environment,
things like carbon dioxide in the air,
things like water, and other nutrients.
And it's able to construct itself
using that energy from the sun.
Now, when it constructs itself,
it not only gives it structure,
but it's also able to store energy.
And right over here, we have
several producers depicted.
We have this tree here, which
is able to do photosynthesis.
We have the grass here that's
able to do photosynthesis,
and it's not just plants.
You have things like algae,
and other microorganisms that
are able to be producers.
But then we have things like this bunny,
and this bunny is not
able to harness energy
from the sun by itself.
In order for it to get
its energy and its matter,
it needs to eat one of these producers,
probably some of this grass.
And so we would call this
bunny right over here,
this rabbit, we would call it a consumer.
And it is a consumer,
you could think of it as
both matter and energy.
When it eats that plant,
those atoms are then able
to make up the bunny.
It will poop out a little bit,
so some of the matter might
end up right over here.
But then also there is energy
that is stored in those molecules,
and that rabbit can use that
energy to exist and live,
but as it does it,
it does release some of the
energy in the form of heat.
And actually, even
producers need to use energy
in order to live.
And as they do that,
they also release heat.
Now we have this fox, the
fox is not a vegetarian.
It does not eat, it does not eat trees.
It likes to eat things
like squirrels and bunnies,
but big picture, it's not
producing its own food.
It's consuming food, so
it also is a consumer.
We can differentiate more in the future
between things that eat plants,
and things that eat other animals.
And you can see in this food web,
we draw an arrow from the
thing that is being consumed
to the thing that is doing the consuming.
So a rabbit consumes a plant,
and so the arrow goes from
the plant to the rabbit.
A fox consumes a rabbit or a squirrel,
so an arrow goes from the rabbit
or the squirrel to the fox.
Now some of you might have noticed
that we have these arrows
that are pointing downward.
And so let me scroll down a little bit.
And we see these
microorganisms, the worms,
the fungi, the mushrooms right over here,
and we call these decomposers.
Now what decomposers are really doing
is what what you would imagine,
breaking down all of the
things that might die,
the poop that is falling down.
And by doing that, it's
continuing to recycle that matter.
And when it decomposes,
those atoms are released
back into the soil,
or the atmosphere,
and then that can be
reused by the producers.
And once again, every
organism in this food web
is using some of the
energy in order to exist,
and do whatever it needs to do.
And some of that energy is being released
as heat in every single situation.